schönen guten Morgen nach Moskau
schönen guten Morgen in einer Situation
in der man in Russland einen Krieg nicht
mehr Krieg nennen darf wie können sie
arbeiten also wie können Sie
herausfinden was die Menschen in
Russland denken
in diesem Sinne hat sich nicht viel
verändert wir führen Umfragen durch und
Menschen Antworten recht offen auf
unsere Fragen also hier hat sich kaum
was verändert
sie sagen etwa 75 Prozent der Russen und
Russinnen unterstützen putinskrieg aber
es sei weniger echte Unterstützung
sondern fehlender Widerstand warum aus
Angst
nein erstens
Russen bekommen verzerrte Informationen
über die Geschehnisse in der Ukraine
da wo die Militäroperation stattfindet
es gibt eine Zensur
es gibt eine aggressive
Propaganda es wird gelügt
man sagt Russland kämpft nicht gegen die
Ukraine sondern gegen ganz Westen und
das macht es für die russische
Gesellschaft nicht einfacher
es wird gesagt die russische
Gesellschaft verspüren eine Gefahr aus
dem Westen die Menschen unterstützen den
Krieg nicht aber
zwangsläufig aus die Situation heraus
unterstützen die Menschen intuitiv eben
diesen Krieg gegen den Faschismus in den
Westen und so weiter es gibt auch Angst
es die Menschen möchten auch nicht
unbedingt
an dem Krieg direkt beteiligt sein
alle diese Faktoren spielen mit rein ja
letztens wurde im russischen
propagandasender RT ja sogar gesagt ist
sei im Grunde ein Bürgerkrieg und Putin
würde nur die richtige Seite bei diesem
Bürgerkrieg unterstützen also das heißt
der russischen Bevölkerung ist nicht
wirklich klar was in der Ukraine
passiert auch weil sie sich nicht
wirklich informieren können oder nicht
informieren wollen
Bevölkerung hat kein klares Bild darüber
was dort passiert
de facto haben wir es mit einem
unbekannten Krieg zu tun
eine klare Vorstellung von dem was
geschieht in der Ukraine
diese Vorstellung haben vier bis zehn
Prozent der Bevölkerung da sind die
Menschen die in der Lage sind um die
Zensur hier rum um die
sperren herum zu forschen und Zugang
haben zu alternativen
Informationsquellen deshalb
circa 15 Prozent der Bevölkerung sind
streng gegen den Krieg und
der Rest die Masse sozusagen
zumindest nach dem Lippenbekenntnis
befürworten Putins Militäroperation in
der Ukraine
aber in der letzten Zeit können wir
sehen
dass dieser
zwangskonsens verwirscht wird man
misstraut immer mehr der offiziellen
Propaganda aber es gibt kaum alternative
Informationskanäle kaum in vom
Alternativen Informationsquellen deshalb
würde ich sagen
entsteht so eine Art
unklarer Zustand
man wartet auf etwas der Blitzkrieg war
ein Fiasko
der Krieg zieht sich nun hin und der
erwartete Krieg über den ukrainischen
Narzissmus ist noch nicht eingetreten
ist beiseite gefegt worden als Ziel und
die ursprünglichen Ziele der
denazifizierung wie das offiziell
ausgedruckt wurde
diese sind schon in den Hintergrund
geraten in dem Vordergrund stehen die
erklärten Ziele der Verteidigung der
Bevölkerung in Donbass und der Krieg
gegen den Westen
Herr Guthoff ich muss jetzt an dieser
Stelle die Frage stellen denn sie haben
jetzt mehrfach das Wort Krieg benutzt
was in Russland verboten ist machen Sie
sich keine Sorgen um sich selbst oder
aber auch um ihr Institut dass ja seit
2016 eh schon auf der Liste der
ausländischen Agenten steht haben Sie
keine Angst
verstehe die reelle Gefahr ist gar nicht
anders sein aber
kreml-propagandisten die benutzen das
Wort Krieg ebenfalls und sie rufen zum
siegreichen Krieg auf bisschen zum
Einsatz von Atomwaffen also trotz aller
Verbote
ist das gang und gäbe dass man das Wort
Krieg benutzt verboten ist es ja nur für
die Opposition natürlich habe ich Angst
um meinen Institut eine kurze Frage noch
könnten denn eigentlich stimmen wie zum
Beispiel die der Popsängerin aller
pugatschowa helfen die den Krieg offen
kritisiert wie einige andere auch
durch ihre Kommentare wurden viel
offiziellen schockiert und die Reaktion
war recht scharf durch die macht aber
diese Kritik von
alla pugatschowa wird
diskutiert in den sozialen Medien aber
wie man so drauf reagieren soll
ja ich würde sagen das ist doch diese
zunehmende Haltung gegen den Krieg
aber eine politische Reaktion werden wir
darauf nicht sehen sagt left goodkov er
ist in Moskau hat sich heute für uns
Zeit genommen und er ist der Chef des
letzten freien
Meinungsforschungsinstituts in Russland
vielen Dank für dieses Gespräch und
alles Gute für Sie
haben sie vielen Dank auf Wiedersehen